hey Theo Brendon its Angie Khan from
upstate New York with a king interesting
and that's just - depending on how you
answer maybe relationship advice
so girls who pay for meals on the first
couple of dates while you're getting to
know somebody
do guys find it intimidating or do they
not really care I'm wondering because I
don't want many second dates with them
and I'm really hoping that it's them
being intimidated and not that they
don't like my personality so I'm looking
for a guy's perspective let me know what
you're thinking keep doing what you're
doing getting gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
girl gang you've been a sidepiece
forever
what do you did you mind people paying
or what I remember I went on a date with
a guy one time second date and she paid
and I still and then I didn't hear from
her after that and I didn't know if I
was I think let me think I didn't know
if I how did she pay though the check
come and she was like I got this one
check came she said you got it last time
oh that's nice and so I didn't I said
well I said I think I can I said I can
get it and she goes no no I got it and I
was like oh I really feel like I should
pay for but I'm gonna let you pay for it
and then she never you never heard from
again
it was never fun but I don't know if
that anything new with it or not I did
she also was a West she'd this lady had
some money so it's not like she was
without she had she had some money I
don't know she was a baller but she had
some money and she had some money that
night I'm old-school man I feel
uncomfortable for girl pays up feel
super uncomfortable especially firstly
especially first date yeah yeah bro
what's the next thing you know open up
my door you know I'm saying yeah no I
don't want that strong women look like
type of dude let's the girl open the
doors for you I've been under a lot of
stress recently this to the year I will
next year I'm would you let your girl
pay all the time yeah
is the first date you were in first date
now first date let me quit being no let
me do it but second third date your
situation say you know she's like listen
you got last time let me get this yeah
it was pretty cool then that seems no
cool but a first date I know no I got no
I don't need anything like
Oh chill cat you'll be paying for your
man yeah every now and then I mean I
don't I don't like people paying for me
a lot of time so I don't like to eat out
a lot
no you're separatist uh no I never ate
out with this cat uh every very rarely
you don't invite her also Brendon no we
definitely do every time cat do you feel
invited or not I feel invited okay yeah
fine Brendon oh I'd let Brendon know if
I didn't feel my true good I feel like
he filed charges against Brendon where
we gonna say Gary puts on a wig and both
y'all fought in a class action against
Brendon
okay and I'll get a section ends I'll
get a nose job and turn it into a set of
tits on my face and I'll join the class
action you'll worry about the class
action the twink who sells your merch
all the time we're gonna get this pig
pay money that's all a dollar a day I
can't work to sell your shirts person oh
yeah who else went to therapy yeah
here's his cheeks out you won't get
yours out dude you want some more shirt
I'm getting my butt out Brendon dude I
want to see you I don't use my body to
sell stuff like you do yeah you okay
wrap myself in cheap gold in children's
trinkets to sell [ __ ] other people
yeah okay I sell to another man their
own Jersey uh what were you saying okay
yeah sorry cat before this guy
interrupted you no problem
first dates depending on who asks you
out to go eat I think it is cool when
the guy pays for the first day and then
girl picks up the second one but if I
asked a guy to go out to eat I don't
automatically think that he's gonna pay
I invited him out
interesting whereas I think girls are
more likely to pay for meals after the
first date if they don't want to see you
again could they don't want to feel like
they owe you a twisted yeah a lot of
good she did you for dinner and drinks
and now he feels like I owe him
something like he deserves to get laid
after this so we'll just pay for the
bill and not that's what she did to you
she was sick your [ __ ] already like I'll
pay I don't remember I'm gonna fill I'll
text her maybe in her or see if I can
get in touch with her and ask her I
could have been it
if you just say yeah I don't want to
deal with this it first dates and a girl
I don't mind if I take you out and then
you pay for like ice cream at the end of
the night or maybe want to address Rand
of drinks just to show like I'm too just
here for the food and drinks you know
yeah I think if a girl pays for the
first date it's a little emasculating to
the guys especially if he's offering
it's kind of a whole move well I think
but though a lot of these ladies they
the feminists they say they want to pay
for it all and then want to pay for
everything
you ain't gonna man like me yeah stop
being a guy you'll probably find one
yeah yeah that's what I say good luck
girl you gotta be team I don't think
it's her personality but quit [ __ ]
Alphen these dudes yeah quit a in these
days
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]